this episode is brought to you by me
undies if I'm not going commando I'm in
me undies I have been testing these
underwear for three to four months now
pretty much every day and in fact
throughout a bunch of my other underwear
this morning and on the road in the
house they are extremely comfortable
they look good feel good they are made
of micro Modell 2 times softer than
cotton as scientifically tested using
the cob bottom method sounds very fancy
of course and I get a lot of compliments
from the ladies for these you don't get
diaper but you don't get the tired
elastic band they look great and they
have underwear for both men and women
check out my undies com forward slash
Tim and you can see everything I've been
wearing they're ridiculous the sublime
everything in between including my
favorite which is called out and I would
be remiss if I didn't mention there
lounge pants this is a new thing and
I've been wearing their lounge pants
when I record podcasts I've been wearing
them out and about when I'm walking the
dog meeting people for coffee and they
are extremely comfortable they're made
from the same material as the underwear
but some of them like the blue ones I
have have pockets so you can walk about
without seeming like you're off of your
meds
and completely crazy so that is awesome
and if you're not happy with the first
pair you try on I assume that refers to
the underwear they'll refund you
completely and you can keep the pair
each right on for free but if you're
that kind of person you should be
ashamed because that's disgusting
me Andy's com4 / Tim check it out
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant
of my own money at least for me in the
team and the company itself so I am an
investor and hope to soon use it as a
client now back to the recommendation as
a Tim Ferriss show listener
you'll get $15,000 managed for free if
you decide to open an account but just
start with seeing the portfolio that
they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
tim hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
this one is an experimental episode as I
often indulge in and it features one of
my favorite writers an inspiring fellow
Paulo Coelho who has long been one of my
writing inspirations his books of near
universal appeal span from the alchemist
to the most recent adultery and his work
has been translated into more than 70
languages who knew there were even 70
languages on the planet and few people
know that the alchemist which was sold
to an original Brazilian publisher which
printed nine hundred copies has now sold
more than 65 million copies worldwide I
expect it's probably more than a hundred
million that original Brazilian
publisher after the nine hundred copy
has declined to reprint it it wasn't
until after his subsequent novel called
Breda
that the alchemist was revived and took
off I for one have always been very
impressed with consistent writers Paulo
averages one book every two years and he
is staggeringly consistent as I am
recording this I'm under the pressure of
deadlines and I more often feel like
Kurt Vonnegut did also one of my
favorite writers and he explains it with
a quote quote when I write I feel like
an armless legless man with a crayon in
his mouth that's most of the time that I
spent writing so my output is erratic at
best and I wondered how does Paulo write
what is his process how does he think
about it and this episode covers a lot
of that it might seem like a niche topic
for this podcast for those of use they
won't let a write or what am I going to
get out of this and what I would
encourage you to think of as you listen
and the audio is a little bit grainy
because he recorded it
Geneva in Switzerland that it showcases
in many ways the struggle and how
someone at the top of their game
who has seemingly beaten all of the odds
still has the daily struggle and I
reached out to him he was kind enough to
reply with the audio that I've included
and he really provides some gems and
answers to the following questions which
I will read right now because he doesn't
always repeat them and here we go so the
first is when on deadline what is the
first thing you do in the morning what
does your daily schedule look like do
you take any days off and what
determines if you've had a quote
successful end quote writing day the
next how do you capture ideas that might
be helpful in your writing these days
what software and tools do you use for
writing next how much of your books do
you visualize your outline upfront
versus writing organically piece by
piece in other words how much of the
story arc have you decided before you
start writing let's take two books as
examples the alchemist and Aleph a le pH
otherwise how did the process differ for
these two books what are your most
common mistakes that you see first-time
novelists making most common weaknesses
do you base your characters on real
people why are why not if not how do you
develop those characters and then last
what are the two to three things you
personally find most invigorating or
helpful when you're stuck or feel
stagnated with writing slash ideas do
you have a team of any type researchers
etc who help you and he also offered a
few other suggestions but well the first
is some context the sentence in Alice in
Wonderland that he mentions is begin at
the beginning the king said gravely and
go on till you come to the end then stop
that is it and he covers a lot on his
YouTube channel and for all of his
musings you can certainly see his
Facebook fan page which is just
facebook.com/hyundaioflouisville absurd
with the incredible Paulo Coelho and I
will link to anything he mentions in the
show notes as well as additional
resources at 4-hour workweek com
for / podcast hello King paulo coelho
pleasure to talk to you looking forward
to to meet you as I said in my email as
for your answers I would try to be as
brief as I can about to deadline I don't
have deadlines I write a book once every
two years and I sit down of course I
have the book inside of me and I start
procrastinating in the morning I check
in my emails I check news I check
everything that I could check or just to
postpone at the moment to see it and
face myself as a writer in front of my
book so let's say that for three hours
I'm trying to tell myself to myself that
oh no no later later later and then one
moment I say okay just not lose the face
in front of myself I'm going to sit and
am I going to write half an hour and I
do and of course it is half an hour
becomes 10 hours in a row that's why I
write my books very quickly because I
cannot stop I cannot stop and and then
of course at night I take a lot of notes
because I missed you in the speed or
writing book order the book the next day
these notes are totally useless the same
thing happens again checking emails
going to social communities post post
postponing procrastinating and and I
cannot I cannot start probably this is
my inner ritual no I have to feel guilty
of not writing for three hours or four
hours but then when I'm dear I start
writing and and no stop
as I said before
to two weeks in two weeks I have the
book ready okay next question my daily
schedule while writing books this is the
one that I just described trying to
escape from my task refraction my books
my novel they were scattered and is in
the morning checking my social
communities answering emails then
walking walking is for me my way of
thinking my way of meditating it's not
that I'm thinking about I am that kind
of transits totally connected with the
present moment
and when I arrived from walking I sit
here and then I start really connecting
to to my social communities I work with
three or four people not more than that
my agent was Alana my office in Brazil
and my webmaster this is the only two
people that three people that have
access to me there's a very strong
shield so I can really use my time to do
what I think I should do to fulfill just
blessing that it was bestowed on me that
was to allow me to to live my personal
legend to became a writer against all
odds because Brazilians not have
different traditions which was later and
besides that the very few authors who
can make a living out of writing nothing
in us but but all over the world however
I was so committed to to my work that
that it was my dream it was my dream
from the very beginning so I really
enjoy what I do I don't I don't work in
fact what I'm doing is really to have
pleasure and have
and have social responsibility towards
my readers myself and the world where I
live
do I take any days off I take many well
back to what I said I forced myself to
give to take two weeks off but not
during the my writing period my writing
period is like I go into a tank and I
only can leave this tank after finishing
the book so I Alice in Wonderland
Lewis Carroll says as Allison in
Wonderland it's very easy to write a
book start in the beginning go through
the middle and go to the end and then
stop that's it no secrets
I can let a quote Blue Square sentence
in an email I don't know it by heart
that's more or less what I said
a successful writing day is the day that
I suffer in the morning and I have fun
in the evening fun by writing a fan I
will not describe this as flies it is
also painful but and is exhausting
because I don't realize that I am
totally connected I mean the kind of
Francis so when I when I go to bed after
10 hours working well the adrenaline is
- this is a still circulating in my
blood so it takes hours to to sleep and
there is note notepad by by my side and
I take notes but I take notes no need to
take them out from my head they would
never use last night next day I never
used notes that I took
only to continue writing and this
happened since I wrote my first book the
pilgrimage I cannot change this process
I wish I could see it and write and not
feel guilty for four or five hours
brains of a is impossible how do I
capture ideas that might be helpful in
your writing I don't I don't I try to
live my life I cry I do live my life and
eventually some subject pops up when the
cycle of two years and and there are
several layers of ideas no I think I'm
going to write a book about this and
then I start and then the second and
then the third but hidden behind all
these books that are not ready to be
written or should never be written it is
the book that I want to be written that
I want to write so and it is the book
that wanted the words could be written I
think it's a much more a decision from
the book then from from the writer and
then when you discovered the first
sentence behind this first sentence
there is a thread that takes you to the
last to the last sentence of the book
let's say let me give you an example
when I wrote the dark abyss I want to
write a metaphor about me about my life
and to be honest I I don't know why did
I choose a shepherd boy and never being
a shepherd I do not do any research on
shepherds not even in Islam I heard
someone when I was in Israel mentioned
mentioning the Five Precepts of Salaam
but the book was here I think that when
you write a book
as it is written in The Alchemist to
connect to the soul of the world you
connect to this energy that I call
inspiration
everybody close installation and then
and there's not that such an effort to
write it as far left I took this nice a
billion journey in 2006 and I never
thought I would be able to write a book
on it why because it's so difficult to
explain this point that contains
everything so I live my experience
traveling for three months I met this I
left this point but I thought that would
be unable to write about it and then I
one day you are a three years ago I was
talking to a friend and she said I got
to write about it at Transylvania no
this long trip I said the first because
I don't feel like writing this second
that because it's not every single
experience that I have in my life that I
want to write on the opposite I write
about a few experiences but not all of
them but Wow and then okay three days
later I got to this inspiration yes I
should write the book is ready and I
started the book with a word that nobody
not start a book which is no nobody does
the book seems no this must lead to be a
bad vibe that said the book is now at
the moment that time we recorded this
interview number one everywhere
it was released Twitter go in in Germany
and it went to number three
one week ago and then just Rica number
two so yeah if you want to capture ideas
you're lost because you you are not
going to live your life you're going to
be capturing ideas they are going to be
detached from the emotions that you need
to be well to live fully
you'll be an observer and not a human
being that is living his or her life
I strongly I strongly
except of course for technical stuff I
strongly encourage writers not to think
about writing everything every time that
they do something
forget notebooks forget taking notes let
what is important remains what's not
important goes away so when you sit down
to write well there is this process or
purge this process or cleansing that
only the important things remain so it's
much more easier than taking notes and
overload yourself with information
software and tools that he was variety I
use I would like to learn about it more
I don't want this podcast to be very
month I know that it is a blog but
basically I use the word and that's all
that's all
having said that a writer today is not a
writer of books he or she must be fully
conscious that the different different
types of writing you can write for books
you can write for mobiles you can write
Twitter you can write blogs and each and
every the platform requires a different
technique this is what is very exciting
for writers today is we are in front of
a new challenge and and you have to
learn how to do it a tweet is not a book
a book is not a tweet
so but please rightist should exercise
training in this in this new techniques
let's forget about the classic format of
books and move to go the way that
internet is now forcing us to to move
forcing I mean encouraging us to - right
yeah as for the story arc there are only
four stories and imma tell destroy your
love story between two people I love
story between three people the struggle
for power and the journey every single
book that it is in a book store deals
with this for arcattack just for things
so you have to decide only among it is
for themes but back it is not in my case
it's not me who decides it is it is the
book itself I'm not saying well the book
is powerful it is an angel that it is
whispering to me what to write oh I'm
not saying I'm not saying that I'm
saying that that normally I have 10,000
books that I feel like writing and at
the end of the day only write one let's
take two book like as examples you said
okay mr. Allen how did your process
differ from these two books they are
very much close one is a metaphor that
it is the alchemist the other one is the
real experience my own experience
however both of them are in the classic
story are
or travel of a journey so they are very
much close they are part of my soul here
that is yeah I think that answer
depression what are the most common
mistakes that is the first time novelist
making the most common mistake is the
first time novelists are always
postponing and then and then they are
very very much insecure when they finish
and they publish a book and you talk to
them and they said oh but you needed to
see my next book this is totally
nonsense
if you go if you talk to many many many
many writers they say that and I don't
understand they really don't understand
why do they say that you cannot
underrate yourself you cannot feel
insecure you cannot you cannot sell your
next book by by despising your your or
underrating your your the book that it
was just published so as for style and
this type of things
don't try to innovate I mean you can
innovate in Twitter Facebook books
Mobile's but not writing a great
storytelling storytelling is the well it
is the since the dark times and then it
is magical and and tell a good story I
see people trying to work so much in
style
you know finding different ways to tell
the same thing and that is like it's
like well it's like fashion No
is the dress but the dress does not
dictate what is inside of the dress the
person so what counts is the person
inside the u.s. not the dress itself of
course I need to write with good taste
and and and another advice that I would
give is that keep it simple keep it
simple use trust her either he or she
has a lot of imagination don't try to
describe things give a hint and they
will fulfill this this hint with their
own imaginary first data why that's why
I am so reluctant to show the rights of
my book to movies because there you have
everything the reader does not need to
think however if I say like Ana laughs
at the very beginning well I am in my
house in the Pyrenees and there is an
oak dear well I don't need to explain
the tea was my house in the Pyrenees and
I only need to put the two elements that
are important the oak myself and the
person that I'm talking to and that's
all so keep it simple
trust your reader understand that he or
she can fulfill the empty spaces don't
over explain most common weaknesses are
first-time novelists of course lack of
self-confidence when when the alchemist
was published it did not sell so the
first publisher gave me their book back
but I was so convinced that I started
knocking the world and and then I find I
found
publisher imagine there was one month in
my life that I could really quit my
dream and if I was not perseverate
enough The Alchemist will not be the
worldwide success as it is today thus
upon the weakness is this could be too
much attention to critics I don't think
it has happened in US but outside of as
critics what they're losing ground very
fast because now internet has this power
of promoting or killing anything but
still writers wants to please their
peers they want to please other writers
they want to be recognized by the
academia by the system forget about this
hope tears you know you should cheer to
share your soul and not and not to
please other writer who is my to write a
review that nobody's going to read just
tell you how good you are and then you
are you are also obliged in the future
to write a review above his books no no
I forget forget this is a video a
weakness don't pay attention and also
not answer to reviewers don't answer to
critics do I base my characters in real
people depends in many books yes I left
of course the problem is my first book
yes no fiction their pocket is but yes
you cannot take something out of nothing
so when you write a book you you use
your experience not your conscious
experience but things that are important
as I said and that remains in you and I
don't I don't
develop my characters I give them them
free reign they they guide me when I
used to read that in biographies or
other writers I said oh just describe
these people they are trying to cheat me
because come on how can a character
guide a writer they are just trying to
make it very mystical very you know like
the we're in an ivory tower but in fact
when I start writing I saw that this is
totally true except of course for some
books that should be based in concrete
experiences in my case it is the
pilgrimage vocalist and an Alex let me
yeah what are the two three things I
find most invigorating or helpful when
you are stuck or feel stagnated with
writing ideas okay there is only one
thing for Daniel two three four when I
am so stagnated
I promise for myself that if I don't
feel inspired I need to move forward I
need to have discipline so and it
happens in the middle of a book No
Here I am we don't know how to continue
the story even if it is a non fiction
story but that is okay if you are
fighting it meeting yeah you book a
fight with me okay
I'm going to sit here and I'm not going
to leave you alone till I find my way
out of this crossroads and and then it
may take ten minutes
it may take ten hours
but if you don't have a discipline
enough you'll not move forward so at the
end of the day Tim writing books is
basically sharing your experience and it
is this is part of the human condition
and if you really are honest if you're
not try to feel a formula to follow a
formula you have to be free to write I
wrote about the prostitution in eleven
minutes I wrote about about madness in
Veronica decides to die so I wrote about
things that are important to me
issues that are important to me and the
you you should be free to write things
that you feel and not trying to repeat
the same formula over and over again so
and I don't have researchers no no no if
I need any research of course when I
wrote a laughs I do not take notes as I
told you I had this fantastic experience
but then I am in a city in the middle of
Siberia and I forgot the name of the
street of the hotel then I do a quick
research that's all but if you overload
your book with a lot of research you're
going to to be very boring to yourself
and to your readers books are not there
to show how intelligent and cultivate
you are books are out there to show your
heart to show your soul and to tell you
your friends readers I'm not alone and I
hope you are not because if you can
identify yourself with my my books or my
words as I can identify yourself with
your garden we have your music with
anything that we do with love thank you
very much joy it is a little bit bit big
my [ __ ] Lord and to send you the
purchase may God bless you as you see oh
hey whoa hey guys this is Tim again just
a few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it
here's why
the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than 10 asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
shows because I use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront yet
because I'm not allowed to here's the
deal they wanted to sponsor this podcast
but because of SEC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have
on the podcast but I've been so
impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get fifteen
thousand dollars managed for free if you
decide to open an account but just start
with seeing the portfolio that they
would suggest for you take two minutes
fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
tip this episode is brought to you by me
undies if I'm not going commando I'm in
the Andes I have been testing these
underwear for three to four months now
pretty much every day and in fact
throughout a bunch of my other underwear
this morning and on the road in the
house they are extremely comfortable
they look good feel good they are made
of micro Modell two times softer than
cotton as scientifically tested using
the cotton method sounds very fancy of
course and I get a lot of compliments
from the ladies for these you don't get
diaper but you don't get the tired
elastic band they look great and they
have underwear for both men and women
check out my undies comm forward slash
Tim and you can see everything I've been
wearing their ridiculous the sublime
everything between including my favorite
which is called out and I would be
remiss if I didn't mention their lounge
pants this is a new thing and I've been
wearing their lounge pants when I record
podcasts I've been wearing them out and
about when I'm walking the dog meeting
people for coffee and they are extremely
comfortable they're made from the same
material as the underwear but some of
them like the blue ones I have have
pockets so you can walk about without
seeming like you're off of your meds and
completely crazy so that is awesome and
if you're not happy with the first pair
you try on I assume that refers to the
underwear they'll refund you completely
and you can keep the pair each ride on
for free but if you're that kind of
person you should be ashamed because
that's disgusting me Andy's com4 slash
Tim
check it out and until next time thank
you for listening
you